le dessous des cartes à issy les
moulineaux depuis 1930 la ville était
dépositaire d'une importante collection
de cartes à jouer les guépards plusieurs
donateurs elle les présente désormais au
public dans un musée qui vient d'ouvrir
ses portes
ce musée de la carte à jouer est unique
en france je vous propose de le
découvrir en compagnie de benoit du but
l'air et des pierres brisent pièce ça
c'est du zombie 9 des cartes
il en a plein les poches collectionneur
passionné michel bodart de voiron dans
l'isère a été le premier à se présenter
aux portes du musée sanctuaire unique en
france qui met à la portée de tous les
arcanes des tares aux anciens de la
luette vendéenne et des cartes japonaise
révolutionnaire italienne ou
publicitaires du 15e siècle à nos jours
ce manque est en france un lieu comme ça
très certainement très certainement
parce que les richesses de la
bibliothèque nationale
sont enfouis dans les bars les réserves
sont réservés à une élite de chercheurs
qui font des études spécialisées et
les le commun des mortels a du mal à
pénétrer ce monde
ce sont des passionnés comme michel qui
ont rendu possible la création du musée
en faisant don à la ville d'issy de
leurs collections et de leurs
compétences
la carte maîtresse de cet ensemble
impressionnant un tarot italien du 15e
siècle véritable petit chef d'oeuvre
renaissance côtoient des milliers de
cartes populaire qui retrace l'évolution
de l'industrie du jeu mais ce sont peut
être les à-côtés de la carte à jouer
les accessoires du joueur ou les
techniques de fabrication qui
intéresseront le plus le visiteur
profane je pense qu'on peut toucher un
public assez vaste parce qu'il ya public
certains ça va s'intéresseront au cinéma
dans ses enseignements à la peinture
d'autres aux règles de jeu et parler les
différentes entrées
quelque part ils pénétreront dans cet
univers une découverte
moi personnellement j'ai fait au fil du
temps parce qu'au départ je voyais la
carte en tant que quart puis y'a quand
même totalement extraordinaire de
georges de la tour dostoïevski le
dessous des cartes n'a jamais cessé de
fasciner
pourquoi pas vous à défaut d'y lire
votre avenir vous y gagnerez un autre
regard sur l'histoire